oui monsieur bébé est ce que je peux
juste ça dure trois langues baisse alors
n'y a pas de bébé alors allez-y comme
l'artichaut
ça fait trois ans que j'enlève oeil à
feuilles tout ce qui est autour et un
jour j'arrive au petit coeur et je ne
mangerai avec une vinaigrette les gaffes
de pâques prendre une feuille de radio
c'est un petit peu sincère comme chez un
petit peu cheap eux seuls ans au montana
j'ai un rendez vous cette semaine
quand avec une avec une personne cette
semaine quand la roue de la semaine
d'ici dimanche et chardy 6 dimanche donc
c'est dommage week end
ce week-end c'est ça nous a peut être ce
soir demain je vous dis pas le jour on
veut savoir réellement une caméra vous
voyez d'où gpac amiens c'est très peu
je suis désolé c'est perso mais si une
personne à laquelle je tiens beaucoup
d'accord j'ai vraiment un doute parce
qu'il ya des messages qui partent un peu
dans tous les sens et je suis perdue
c'est quoi le dernier médecin a fait
deux mois qu'on chine fait quoi dans les
messages passés
oui j'accepte de dîner mais ça s'est un
peu froissé alors c'est à dire froid
c'est à dire dans quel sens je vous
savez je connais les relations humaines
vous pouvez tout nous demander et bains
froids cdaf coach veut maintenant oui
rien dans ce mot sur qu'est ce qu'est la
nba c'est à dire que pendant une semaine
il peut y avoir un petit tu me manques
et la semaine d'après cette même
personne te parle comme comme si tu
étais c'est pas moi mais il est
lunatique laisse tomber ça vaut pas le
coup
d'accord apparemment c'est un fou il
s'est passé mais voilà et du coup j'ai
même perdu et comme si quelqu'un pour
une fois ça arrive peut-être tous les
cinq ou dix ans qu'elle est vierge de
connexion qui a eu quelque chose
j'ai eu peur touillage mais il ya eu un
galoche c'est tout c'est les choses
compliquées
et comme c'est compliqué automatiquement
sabbath ou tu vois quoi william saurin
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
voilà oui la passion pour le coup
critique christine kristin c'est sincère
et c'est important pour les 6 lundi soir
samedi soit oui il y aura même une
proposition pour un week-end à rome sous
eau par auquel on a déjà fait un
week-end sans corps akwaba week-end un
petit weekend du tout les deux temps à
quelque chose de bien et on va jusqu'au
bout et iv du mois qui vient d'aboutir
mais dans une agence de voyages sont la
voix de l'histoire
ah bah oui il y aura pas non pas par
abba
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la nouvelle c'est le week end je vais
pas payer tous les week-ends
sk 28 bat bien sûr ah bon c'est bon
alors jusqu'au bout de cette histoire
pour en savoir un peu plus sur cette
personne qui vous paie si ça ça vaut en
savane petit peu plus tôt bio et soit
pas curieux à mon choix c'est quoi et
papa brûle pas les étapes
complètement taré tard il apparaît donc
vous avez raconta kg par mois et ses 6
passes et traille plc une amie vous
c'est vous racontez pas senoussi ya une
relation des plus savoureuses
je fais quand je vous ramène un truc à
la fois ça vous fait rire et ça vous
êtes ça vous énerve m'était complètement
raté votre chance
cyril maintenant frère à ses lapins
selectrip toi toujours deux fois à fear
non mais j'ai pas dû tomber dit pas si
je pourrai prendre l'avion ça marche
mais bon je suis pas du tout l'être dans
la série en tout cas brûler avec mon
frère des coudes avec quelque chose à
dire
n'hésitez pas